bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
cette ut week-end l'émission dédiée aux
sorties et vos loisirs au sommaire de ce
numéro il sera question de danse avec la
compagnie yeraz qui se produisent ce
samedi à saint cyr l'école
elle vous invite à une découverte des
traditions arménienne à travers le rêve
et le voyage
il sera aussi question de musique
costumes et rollers puisque c'est le
savoureux mélange que proposent les
chocs d'elancourt sur le thème du
carnaval vous pouvez passer un bel après
midi entre amis et famille et nous
parlerons autoportrait puisque c'était
le thème de notre concours photo de ce
mois ci
claude chose de président de l'union
régionale photographique nous présentera
les résultats
l'irak veut dire rêve en arménien et
c'est vers ce but que tant le rêve de
nos montagnes
le spectacle de la compagnie virage et
christina gassion à vous dire bonjour
vous êtes la chorégraphe de la compagnie
alors est-ce que déjà vous pouvez
m'expliquer quelle est l'histoire de ce
spectacle l'histoire de ce spectacle il
raconte tout d'abord des traditions des
rites et traditions du mariage en
première partie et la deuxième partie
raconte elle est plus universel
je les crée en puisant dans mes
souvenirs d'enfance les plus profonds et
en m'appuyant aussi sur mon vécu en
france et ça raconte la vie la mort la
naissance l'amour
les séparations les retrouvailles fait
une histoire tout ce qui fait la vie le
bonheur le partage la joie
l'amour la douleur vous parler vos
souvenirs parce que vous êtes né en
arménie
vous avez quitté à 18 ans mais ce sont
vos racines vous aimez présentait aussi
aux gens oui bien sûr j'ai quitté
l'arménie à l'âge de 19 ans avec mes
parents et l'exil a provoqué une faille
en moins et j'ai eu le besoin de me
relier à cette perte de nouveau et de la
danse arménienne a été ce langage
universel qui m'a permis de me
rapprocher tout en intégrant mon pays
d'accueil
mon pays et raconter des histoires à
travers la danse arménienne dans mon
pays d'accueil
il n'y a pas que de la danse annonce un
spectacle aussi un peu de théâtre ce que
vous avez une formation théâtrale
oui effectivement j'ai fait le cours
florent en france et j'ai travaillé
notamment avec un metteur en scène et
comédien de génie qui est simon abkarian
et c'est grâce à cette pratique de
théâtre j'ai pu me délivrer un petit peu
des schémas préexistant de danse
arménienne et j'ai pu me laisser libre
cours à la création non pas moderne mais
de puiser vraiment dans mon vécu entre
l'orient et l'occident
on va regarder ce mariage parce que je
vous propose
regardez un extrait maintenant
non
il ya énormément de danseurs des
costumes c'est ça aussi l'arménie c'est
toute cette tradition évidemment ce
spectacle raconte l'histoire des
arméniens mais avec du recul et de la
distance
je peux vous dire que ce spectacle
raconte avant tout la joie dans ces de
tous et c'est une espèce de célébration
au pluriel des paradis perdu est à venir
parce que on dit que pour savoir où on
va il faut savoir d'où l'on vient et je
pense que ce spectacle est aussi le
témoignage de ce peuple qui était voué à
disparaître après le génocide de 1915
des arméniens et ccc le témoignage de ce
peuple qui est toujours là et qui a la
joie de vivre ça c'est de montrer qu'il
a une histoire outre je ne sais d'eux
qu'on connaît plus souvent l'arménien on
connaît très peu de pays finalement oui
oui bien sûr le rôle de l'artiste c'est
évidemment de s'occuper de sauvegarder
la tradition l'esthétique des mouvements
le codes de la danse mais c'est aussi
raconter l'histoire du peuple parce que
de toute façon la danse
chaque peuple à ses traditions ses
moeurs et la danse est un moyen
important pour révéler la psychologie le
tempérament d'un peuple et son passé
historique
donc si la danse est universel ça parle
à tout le monde la danse c'est ce qui
échappe à la raison c'est elle exprime
l'indicible ce que les corps raconte
c'est loin de la parole c'est l'émotion
c'est tout ce qu'on ressent à
l'intérieur et c'est un langage
d'émotion il ya des passages aussi
beaucoup plus doux beaucoup plus fort
dans votre spectacle
c'est ça c'est aussi vous parler du rêve
du rêve bruit je pense que le rôle d'un
artiste c'est notamment de faire rêver
les gens c'est de secouer le public
c'est d'offrir un séisme d'émotion de
les éloigner du quotidien de la routine
de les évadés voulait faire réfléchir de
les rendre plus généreux de les élever
de de se purifier nous mêmes en tant
qu'artiste et d'offrir une vibration de
coeur aux gens qui sont dans la salle et
qui le parts de ce spectacle en gardant
ce rêve et ce moment magique et que ça
transforme l'eau lui
je ne pense qu'on pouvait pas mieux
finir pour donner envie aux gens d'aller
voir alors si vous voulez voyager en
arménie c'est au théâtre gérard philipe
e200 cyr l'école
le rêve de nos montagnes est à découvrir
à 20h30 le samedi 19 mars
merci christina gassion agoudjian il est
venu là cela peut vous merci
eva d'été est une slameuse reconnu de
mantes la jolie et elle expose jusqu'au
25 mars au conservatoire des arts de
montigny le bretonneux regarder le sujet
de sephora mamani sur des images de
patrick jacques de dixmude s'exprimer au
travers de l'art une révolte une
souffrance une lutte et va dt slameuse
et poète originaire du mantois propose
un travail engagé autodidacte en arts
plastiques qu'elle accompagne de ses
textes bien nombreux textes qui sont
relativement fort et assez assez brut
donc qui relate de son histoire et de
son passé qui est un petit peu difficile
et donc la traduction pictural sur son
travail est essentiellement liée à la
condition de la femme condition de la
femme relations hommes-femmes ou vision
du corps féminin autant de thèmes
traités sur papier aux matériaux de
récupération par l'artiste elle
travaille ses créations sans pinceau
avec ses mains ou des bâtons en mille en
acrylique huile et pastel
ce qui nous a plu c'est vraiment ce
travail très brut très spontanée avec
cette émotion qui est très forte que ce
que l'émotion soit positive ou négative
on ne rentre pas nous on ne sort pas de
cette exposition sans avoir rien
ressenti et c'est ça aussi qui nous
intéresse c'est à dire de un moment se
dire les arts plastiques ce n'est pas
gratuit il faut que ça exprime quelque
chose ces créations sombre coloré brut
spontanée à la frontière de l'abstrait
pour certaines sont à découvrir au
conservatoire des arts plastiques de
montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au 25 mars
prochain dans le cadre des ateliers
d'histoire organisé par la ville des
clayes-sous-bois d'anciens que les siens
se sont réunis pendant un an pour
réaliser l'exposition souvenirs
d'enfance de 1930 à 1960
cette exposition est présentée jusqu'au
10 avril aux communs du château des
clayes-sous-bois leurs témoignages et
objets anciens est clair les thèmes de
la vie quotidienne comme l'enfance
l'école la famille le travail ou encore
la religion un moyen de lire l'évolution
de la société de 1930 à 1960
les détails avec muriel raoult et daniel
volders laurent à partir de toutes ces
thématiques
eh bien on a pu effectivement
les les alimenter les agrémenter avec
les témoignages les photos que chacun
personnellement à apporter est également
ensuite des objets pour illustrer les
modes de vie voilà qui pouvait exister
de 1930 à 1960
j'ai participé à cette exposition en
mettant par écrit nous souvenir
d'enfance du début jusqu'à la gesco
années 60 inclus et rechercher nos
photos pour appuyer nos photos donc bas
notre famille était pas mal sur les
affiches
et puis rechercher les objets qui nous
ont pris du temps on change maintenant
complètement de sujets parce que nous a
rejoint plateau wissem jaubert bonjour
vous êtes en charge de la section roller
hockey loisirs des chocs ce d'elancourt
votre club organise ce dimanche une
disco roller
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce
qu'ils nous disent corolla alors une
disco roller en fait c'est un peu le
même principe que si on va en patinoire
samedi soir ou tout simplement on aura
une un thème musical et on va patiner
autour de autour de la patinoire
donc là cette fois ci par contre c'est
en rollers s'être ouvert à tout le monde
c'est ouvert à tout le monde oui les
plus débutants ceux qui ont un peu
un problème de confiance et en roller il
ya des bénévoles des membres de
l'association qui seront là pour donner
des petits cours et des conseils pour
être sûr de rester debout sur les
rouleurs c'est une activité familiale
afin aussi entre amis ça va c'est à dire
entre amis entre familles c'est valable
pour les deux c'est à dire que si on a
des amis qui veulent venir qu'ils
viennent généralement c'est aussi très
familial parce que quand il ya des
enfants et des parents et grands parents
qui aiment bien aussi venir donc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui se partagent
amis et notre famille ça peut permettre
aussi de faire découvrir la pratique et
le club c'est aussi le but c'est un peu
pour nous une sorte de deuxième porte
ouverte
vu qu'on accueille beaucoup de gens qui
sont vraiment extérieur
à l'association ça nous permet de faire
connaître l'association notre nom notre
notre image et notre culture est
derrière d'avoir peut-être de nouveaux
licenciés pour l'année suivante pour
peut-être donner envie à ces nouveaux
licenciés ça va se passer comment ce
sont des activités libres où il y aura
des petits ateliers alors globalement
c'est une activité livrent donc ce sera
de 14 heures à 18 heures avec vraiment
majoritairement une activité libre mais
de temps en temps on arrêtera un peu
cette activité lit pour faire des jeux
c'est à dire on va dire chenille voilà
les grands jeunes et des jeux de vitesse
on va faire des courses de petites
compétitions enfants et puis ensuite
adultes débutants et voilà via un thème
particulier cette fois c'est le carnaval
il faut venir déguisés ou c alors il me
recommande le déguisement parce que
c'est toujours plus marrant ce genre
plus rigolo après s'il ya pas
déguisements n'y en a pas alors cette
année le thème c'est le carnaval
donc on l'avait choisi parce qu'il ne le
dit pas de bêtise le carnaval en italie
bientôt lieu
donc voilà on l'a avec le rapprochement
des dates on s'était dit que ce serait
une bonne thématique on avait jamais
exploités
cette vidéo c'est de s'amuser avec la
musique dans l'exacte eux compléter la
fête avant il faut préciser les rollers
ne sont pas fournis il faut venir que
ses propres dollars contrairement à une
patinoire on vient aussi louer des pas
des patins à glace là cette fois ci nous
on n'a pas de stock et on demande aux
personnes de venir avec leurs propres
patins une petite nouveauté parce que
vous faites souvent des disco roller
deux fois par an vous proposer cette
année une tombola
alors cette année on fait une tombola
c'est à dire qu'avec chaque entrée
deux personnes c'est un ticket de
tombola en plus et à la fin il y aura la
remise des prix petit volant petit
détail des cadeaux peut-être à gagner
baverez bon nom sera la surprise
ce sera la surprise alors merci wissem
jaubert si vous voulez faire du roller
danser mais surtout profité d'un après
midi en famille et entre amis
c'est là prenez la direction du gymnase
chastanet bettencourt dimanche 20 mars
si ce week-end vous êtes plutôt tenté
par un bon ouvrage laurent garin du pavé
du canal à montigny le bretonneux vous
propose une colère noire à l'être à mon
fils de taille les six côtes
l'auteur parle de racisme anti noirs aux
états unis je vous laisse leur hangar à
nous le présenter bonjour aujourd'hui je
vous présente tena izy côte qui est un
journaliste américain d'une quarantaine
d'années donc c'est son premier ouvrage
est donc là il va écrire une lettre à
son fils d'une quinzaine d'années sur la
condition est sur la position des hommes
noirs dans la société américaine
donc il prend en fait lui comme contexte
sa position à lui en tant que jeune donc
l'éducation qu'il a pu recevoir de son
père qui lui descendait des esclaves et
donc tout tout son vécu et tous ont
ressenti vis-à-vis de la position du
corps noir vous qu'ils utilisent
extrêmement sous lens terme la de corps
noir dans la poésie dans la société
américaine et donc on voit en fait c'est
plus une explication sur le contexte de
la naissance du racisme aux états unis
que sur quelles sont les solutions que
j'ai qu'il faut y apporter c'est juste
voilà un acte de fait sur la position du
noir dans la société american dance qui
finalement est très intéressant dans ce
livre enfin c'est de voir les évolutions
déjà son père tanaisie côte a connu une
situation du noir dans dans la société
lui en a connu forcément une différente
son fils va forcément si on connaît une
différente parce que déjà il ya un
président américain noir et donc voilà
c'est ces évolutions la de la société
américaine et du racisme et le
la préface qui est fait par mon bon coup
qui dit quand même qu'il ya des
différences entre la société française
et la société américaine
on n'a pas les mêmes façons de gérer ce
racisme la vis à vis des noirs mais qui
a quand même des ponts qui existe et ça
permet quand même de pousser aussi la
réflexion sur notre société à nous et
sur ce que devient la france et son
racisme on continue ce 7,8 week-end
l'édition dédiée vous sortez vos loisirs
en parlant de photographier et plus
précisément de notre concours photo
ce mois ci a été question
d'autoportraits claude chose bonjour
bonjour mais l'ami vous êtes le
président de l'union régionale
photographique sud ouest ile de france
et vous êtes prévenus nous présenter les
résultats
première question à ce que les
participants ont été inspirés par ce
thème l'écouté mélanie bien sûr on a eu
quand même des photos qui était fort
fort bien fait vous les avez vus aussi
vous avez vu toute la série les gens ils
ont fait vraiment réalisé l'auto
portrait et non le selphy comme on leur
avait demandé
vous pouvez nous préciser la différence
alors le selphy c'est une photographie
qu'en pratique souvent avec son
téléphone portable mais aussi avec son
appareil photo
puisqu'il existe des canes qui quelque
part et une photo que pour montrer le
lieu où on se trouve
c'est à dire valoriser le lieu où on se
trouve g j'habite versailles suppléer
moi je dis souvent dans le parc parce
que c'est un lieu de promenade et on
s'aperçoit que les gens il faut se font
photographier pour montrer qu'ils sont à
versailles alors que l'auto portrait des
scouts et c'est quelque chose où on se
montre tel qu'on est
sans artifice sans montrer le lieu et
écoutez vous avez vu mélanie les photos
elle était vraiment très très bien
réussi d'ailleurs je crois qu'on va en
voir quelques-unes des cinq premières
on va voir les cinq qui se sont destinés
à aider distingué dans le jury a estimé
la première convoi qui fait 4e ex-aequo
c'est celle de donato altérée qu'est ce
qui a plu au jury
écoutez je trouve que c'est une photo
très contemporaine où ce monsieur si
vous voulez cette personne assez montré
avec sa passion qui est le bel 20 se
voulait très certainement et en plus il
s'est dédoublé c'est une photo
contemporaine qui a été travaillée qui
était monté je trouve que c'est une très
très belle très belle image si vous
voulez donc voilà exactement et que
cette même photo c'est celle de roger de
même alors voilà roger tmc faisait
photographier lui même
et puis je crois qu'il en a fait deux
photos dans le dans le classement et à
celle ci qui est en couleur et mais qui
est classée aussi 4e ex-aequo
moi j'avoue que je préfère la troisième
qui a qui donne vous avez le regard de
ce monsieur
voilà il ya ce côté un peu à la scie
mais non si vous voulez donc l'auteur de
romans policiers sous les dents que qui
qui se montre un petit peu comme gabin
s'ils voulaient dans l'est dans toutes
les tous les films qu'il a fait sur la
quantité commissaire de police le
passais d'éclairage il ya une question
d'éclairage elle est vraiment très bien
fait
moi j'avoue que c'était une photo qui
m'a vraiment interpellé mais vous savez
ma mélanie je ne participe pas au
classement donc voilà et là c'est la
seconde place c'est celle elle est pour
manuel que caro oui bah voilà qui est
splendide cette photo qu'est ce qui a
permis qu'elle savait écouter cette
photo je trouve que elle est pleine de
douceur
elle est pleine de c'est une c'est une
image qui nous amène à partir dans le
rêve à imaginer essayé de traduire la
pensée de cette personne pour pouvoir et
essayer de mieux la comprendre je trouve
que c'est une très très belle photo si
bien réussi et je vous dis oh
globalement toutes les photos que nous
avons su à peu près une trentaine et
bien écoutez on avait de très belles
choses dans tout dans toutes ses photos
particulièrement sorti du lot c'est pas
un gagnant parce que pour montrer que
des noms d'hommes mais c'est une
gagnante elle est avec nous en plateau
hélène angoulvant bonjour j'aimerais
retourner tout de suite vers claude
d'abord pour qu'ils m'expliquent ce qui
a vraiment plu dans cette photo tel
engouement
eh bien écoutez cette photo je crois que
c'est la partie flou le l'imaginaire de
d'hélène qui a fait que les gens parce
que globalement il a été cité première
ou deuxième par les quatre membres du
jury et hélène avait fait en avait
envoyé plusieurs chocs cible et hélèna
et et imaginative
elle a essayé de nous faire participer à
son voyage dans le rêve est bon je
dirais que c'est une très jolie photo
donc mais je crois que le mieux c'est
devant plus de poser la question et on a
dû
mal à croire que c'est une photographie
vous pouvez m'expliquer comment elle a
été faite alors tout d'abord c'était de
voir un écran blanc j'avais mon ami mon
appareil sur un pied photo et j'ai
utilisé un intervallomètre c'est à dire
qu'il lançait le déclenchement toutes
les cinq secondes à peu près et avec une
pause lente de trois secondes
voilà donc j'ai essayé j'ai deux c'était
un exercice pour moi en fait et j'ai
essayé de bouger sur cette photo pour
voir ce que ça ce que ça pouvait donner
puis puis j'ai trouvé que c'était ça me
va et très esthétique c'est très vrai
que le sensation de fluidité
on sent que c'est une super position de
photos c'est très impressionnant et
l'autoportrait qu'est ce qui vous a plu
dans ce thème c'est pas nécessairement
facile de se mettre face à l'objectif
non c'est quelque chose même qui est
très difficile pour moi et bien là
j'étais tout seul donc j'avais pas de
témoins donc je me suis habillé chat
potté
et puis c'était un exercice
photographique pour moi réellement parce
que je voulais découvrir un petit peu
l'exercice de l'autoportrait mais aussi
de la pause lente par voilà et puis pour
une première c'est quand même très s'est
ouvert et cela gagnants de notre
concours vous y attendiez non absolument
pas nouvelle surprise sur prise est bon
merci beaucoup
hélène angoulvant pardon excusez moi
j'espère que vous ferez mélanie au nom
de nom du président de la fédération
photographique de france vis à vis des
chiens qui m'a demandé de remettre à
hélène se livrent à la pause pour son
premier prix donc voila merci beaucoup
nous ont remerciés hélène d'avoir
participé à ce concours
mais je crois qu'au si on peut remercier
tous les autres participants parce que
c'était vraiment c'était un très très
beau travail en équipe et êtes très
difficile et très intéressant parce que
comme on le dit si vous laissez pas
toujours facile de se meut de se mettre
devant l'objectif
parce que plein de choses passent à
travers ciblées de regards étaient donc
voilà là on est à l'autoportrait ce mois
ci mais le mois prochain pour photo
continuer le mois prochain qu'est ce que
quels défis vous lancer alors nous
sommes sur saint quentin en yvelines
ville nouvelle par excellence puisque
décidé je crois dans les années 60
eh bien on va parler de l' architecture
contemporaine je crois que pour avoir
moi même fait des photos sur
saint-quentin puisque j'y ai habité
pendant très longtemps
il ya des choses qui sont surprenantes
et bien on parle de le thème sera l'
architecture contemporaine
nous vous demandons de bien vouloir
envoyer vos photos à sa 6ème voilà à
redaction arobas tv fil 78 points comme
on va dire que cela vers l'oubli de dire
la date
j'ai pas date on va dire avant le 18
avril 7 avril
donc c'est à noter dans vos agendas
l'adresse vous a été donné n'hésitez pas
envoyez nous vos plus beaux clichés et
12 sur 50 ans divine
on n'oublie pas mais il ya de quoi faire
quand on est pas on s'arrête pas ciblé à
51 18 mai sachant qu'on est dans cette
ville qui est absolument contemporaine
et il ya de très belles choses à faire
et voilà affûtez votre regard et vous
verrez que vous découvrir des choses
très intéressant et comme hélène
angoulvant le gagnant ou la gagnante
sera reçue en plateau et aura bien sûr
un cadeau on était tous les deux moi je
vous dis à bientôt mélanie bonne pleine
journée
on adore les photographies on va partir
au cinéma parce que si vous souhaitez
les dans les salles obscures syrie la
date du cinéma philippe noiret des
clayes-sous-bois vous donne son coup de
coeur de professionnels au lait coûte
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film les innocentes pologne décembre
matile de beaulieu une jeune interne de
la croix-rouge chargé de soigner les
rescapés français avant leur
rapatriement est appelée au secours par
une religieuse polonaise
d'abord réticente mathilde accepte de la
suivre dans son couvent ou 30
bénédictine vivent coupés du monde
elle découvre que plusieurs d'entre
elles tombées enceintes dans des
circonstances dramatiques sont sur le
point d'accoucher
le film parle de l'après guerre en
pologne et des femmes sur un fait mal
connu mais parfaitement authentique le
film dégage profondeur et intensité il
met en lumière le tragique de l'histoire
en s'attachant à la vérité humaine et à
la beauté formelle le spectateur sera
touchée par l'amitié entre des femmes
que leur foi séparent mais finalement
réunis par le même amour de leur
prochain le film envoûté emporte
jusqu'au final inattendu ce drame
historique bouleversant est une réussite
du cinéma français
pourquoi this way environ tant que
johnny n'aurait pas seulement besoin de
l'aide de dieu
tous les jours je la ville tout ce qui
s'est passé dans le bourg
perdu la foi mais nous abondons n'est
pas assez bon
je suis là pour les aider dites moi
comment prendre
les innocentes et à découvrir cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
l'édition 2016 de mort par se déroule du
19 au 30 mars à l'espace albert camus
c'est l'occasion de découvrir les
oeuvres d'une centaine d'artistes locaux
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
amoureux de handball le tournoi
international junior féminin
qualificatif pour le championnat du
monde 2007 en russie est organisée ce
vent de ce vendredi 18 au dimanche 20
mars au palais des sports pierre de
coubertin à plaisir quatre pays dont la
france s'affronteront dans ce mini
tournoi pour gagner leur billet pour la
compétition
seule la première place est
qualificative et les rencontres sont
ouvertes au public
alors laissez vous tenter on conclut
avec un dernier rendez-vous qui est lui
aussi sportif à partir de 9h30 ce
dimanche 20 mars
c'est la course de printemps à voisins
le bretonneux esprit convivial familial
et sportif est garanti voilà le petit
week-end est terminée je vous remercie
de nous avoir suivis la semaine
prochaine c'est ci fera namani qui vous
donnera encore des nouvelles idées
sorties et loisirs
moi je vous souhaite un excellent week
end